yeah so my dad and my mom have been
pilots for forever
so i just really grew up in this
aviation family and so so flying really
just was a natural thing for me
um so i've been flying for my whole life
and i decided to get on a sudden
adventure
but sarah there's a big difference
between flying
um every now and again with your parents
and flying around the world
on your own
yeah a little bit um i just thought you
know i've got
i'm taking a gap year i've got some
spare time why not do something crazy
and uh change my life a bit
well it's certainly um fascinating and a
little bit hairy i'm guessing at times
tell me
about how you've prepared for it and the
route
sure so i've been flying i mean this
week already i've done about 40 hours of
flying
so preparation has been pretty crazy and
especially for safety i need to make
sure that i'm as safe as possible
especially so i'll be going west from
belgium
and that will bring me through greenland
and you know places like alaska
and south america which is near the
equator where the weather can be a bit
iffy
um so i need to make sure that you know
as prepared as they can be especially
for the
really tall mountains in alaska in
greenland as well as
you know sometimes dodgy weather in
south america and near south
south asia and you know exactly where
you're going to land
and there are plans for when you get
there and somewhere to sleep and eat
etc or do you have to expect the
unexpected
it's a bit of both aviation you never
really know especially weather-wise
um but i will be i've been really lucky
that many people have offered to help
and you know let me stay at their homes
all around the world which is really
amazing so i'll be staying at people's
homes sometimes hotels in very remote
places
but but i'm really excited and can't
wait how long do you think it's going to
take you
it should be about two to three months
hopefully but again weather dependent it
could take longer it could be shorter
no one really knows and how long and
what are you most looking forward to
and what are you least looking forward
to
looking forward to i'm really looking
forward to i mean meeting so many new
people and all the different cultures
and the food obviously
um but i'd say the one thing i'm afraid
of is you know the unexpected so
things always come up you never know
what it's going to be it could be
weather it could be just
you know technical things with a plane
or luckily i've got a great plane
right behind me um but yeah i'm afraid
of the unexpected
but also excited for that so yeah i'm
sure
yeah zara um please keep in touch with
us as you go around
the world and when you come back and
you've had a little bit of a rest
i believe that eventually you want to be
an astronaut is that right
to be an astronaut is that right that's
the dream yeah hopefully one day
uh i'll be able to go a bit higher okay
well i know that richard branson watches
the show so hopefully he's watching and
he might take you
into space at some stage in the future
uh good luck
keep well stay safe keep in touch with
us sarah well done